time to fix angler merkel's hairdo the
long journey has taken its toll
this wax figure was sent all the way
from shanghai china to bremerhaven in
northern germany
now it graces the back room of alexis
values restaurant
i have a new necklace this one doesn't
suit her the chinese scent
i have another one one she likes
i did my research
[Music]
has greek roots and grew up in germany
he's a huge fan of chancellor angela
merkel which is why he ordered this
marco figure for his greek restaurant
he's already got a life-size cardboard
cut out of merkel
once he even met his idol in person
she sent me this autograph thank you
very much and all the best signed by
developed a liking for angela merkel 10
years ago during the greek financial
crisis
he was outraged when he saw athens
protesters vilify merkel as a nazi
that really really bothered me
that's why i invited the chancellor to a
greek restaurant i wanted to meet her
and show her a different side of greece
these images from that time are so out
of place in europe
despite his evident loyalty the german
chancellery did not endorse putting up
the life-size merkel figure in the
restaurant
even though none of his guests mined
[Music]
everyone's allowed their own opinion
after all
i don't see any reason to laugh or mock
it it's totally fine
but it's a tough time for the restaurant
owner now that merkel's reign is
but in this greek restaurant angela
merkel will always be the one and only
chances